a lot of people are wondering if Marcus
Smart is going to change his hair from
green to blue now that he's treated to
the Grizzlies but here's the thing that
people are getting all wrong smart
didn't dye his hair green to match the
Celtics Jersey color he dyed his hair to
honor his mother who died in 2018 after
a battle with cancer his mom Camellia
had always loved his hair in the
different styles he wore it in growing
up and before she passed his mama had
said she wanted to see his hair green
but she sadly never got the chance to
see it it's certainly possible that
smart might change his hair color before
his first game in Memphis but that's a
decision he'll make on his own time
surely